and we begin with this newly released
body camera video shows a dramatic
moment Arizona police officers rescued a
baby left inside a hot car
Stacey Holly was arrested in June after
forgetting her five-month-old in a
target parking lot for nearly an hour
the infant did survive fortunately Kris
Van Cleave is following this story
Kris how exactly did this happen well
good morning the distraught mother has
heard over and over again saying that it
was an accident and she doesn't know how
she forgot her baby was in that car and
that's a shockingly common answer when
these things happen time and time again
the parents say they simply forgot the
baby was there it's something that has
turned deadly at least 85 times in the
last two years alone this is the moment
37 year old Stacy Hawley realized she
did the unimaginable Hallie forgot her
five month old baby daughter inside her
car parked in the hot Arizona Sun while
she shopped at a Target with her sister
and six-year-old daughter surveillance
video shows Holly walking inside the
store then nearly an hour later she
heads back to the car realizes what's
happened and calls 911
while the temperature outside was 100
degrees inside a car it can jump to 134
in just 30 minutes I think on average 38
children die a year in hot cars in the
United States so far this year that
number is hit at least 35 last month in
New York one year old twins Phoenix and
Luna died after their father 39 year old
Iraq war veteran juan rodriguez
accidentally left them in a hot car
while he went to work holly is heard on
tape thanking the police calling her
arrest I open it you understand the
seriousness of what happened
okay 1,000% and again her child was okay
Congress is now considering a law that
would require new cars to come standard
with a warning system to alert drivers
about somebody in the back seat some
vehicles already come with that feature
now holly has been charged with
endangerment and reckless child abuse
she pleaded not guilty Anthony yeah
thank you Chris I mean you know as she
says you you see these stories and you
think how can anybody do this apparently
it's easier than we think
yeah III would agree and I don't I don't
think charging her with endangerment and
child abuse is gonna make her become a
better mother suddenly it's gonna make
it a lot more difficult actually she's
fighting now a legal battle it's a
tricky situation because you want to
deter it but at the same time you're
adding more difficulty I did a story
about this once and experts suggest
leaving your purse or a cellphone in the
backseat if your baby's in the car seat
that way you remember that I bet
cellphones are involved a lot in these
distracted cases